sein Lager hier drüben war auch
verlassen im Kampf gegen den Kältetod
auf Berlins Straßen Kältebus Berliner ST
hallo jede Nacht im Einsatz für
Obdachlose hast du alles was du
brauchsteffe Kaffee Essen
Schlafsack niemand wird
zurückgelassen ich
[Musik]
Br stmion Antonia wier und Matthias
matzester bereiten sich auf eine kalte
Nacht
[Musik]
vor Schlafsäcke und Isomatten ist jetzt
bei den Temperaturen das
wichtigste ansonsten Tee Kaffee und uns
natürlich klar aber 5 Minuten terin weil
ist eine kleine Mahlzeit die auch noch
mal
wärmpendet die beiden fahren mit dem
Kältebus durch die Hauptstadt
Obdachlosen hen schon kurz nach
Einsatzbeginn ist das Tablet voll mit
Aufträgen Meldungen von besorgten
Berlinern ich habe auch das Gefühl dass
seit Corona irgendwie noch mal mehr
Menschen auf der Straße sind weil
einfach mehr Menschen durch System
gerutscht sind und was ich auch
auffällig finde dass es immer mehr
Menschen in psychischen ausnahmituation
sind an die man sehr sehr schwer
rankommt Kurfürst Damm Berlins NOB
Einkaufsmeile erster Einsatz bei einem
Mann aus Polen ein Bekannter du bist du
bist dünn geworden nein
nein na dann machen wir mal machen wir
mal ein Tee für dich möchtest du auch
noch so eine 5 Minuten terine seit 1994
ist der Kältebus im Einsatz jeden Winter
es ging los nachdem damals ein
Obdachloser in Berlin erfroren war also
wir kennen ihn schon er hält sich ja
dauerhaft auf dann fahren mal vorbei
gucken wie es ihm geht fragen was er
braucht jetzt hat er Lust
auf kleine warme Mahlzeit sage ich mal
noch ein heißen Tee und er ist halt
einer von den Personen der nie in der
Notübernachtung mitkommen will sondern
den wir dann immer vor Ort versorgen auf
der Straße versorgt wird
genau 2000 Menschen gelten in Berlin
offiziell als obdachlos viele sind von
außerhalb in die Stadt
[Musik]
gekommen gerne hab eine gute Nacht ja
pass auf Dich
auf also wenn man sich die Zahlen
und die ich sag mal die
zuwanderungsströme dann ist das ja auch
logisch gerade aus Osteuropa ist Berlin
ja quasi die erste Anlaufstelle für für
alle Menschen die nächste Meldung kommt
aus einem willenviertel am Stadtrand in
einer Nebenstraße ein Schlafsack quer
auf dem
Gehweg ist der Schlafsack dick genug ist
ja
warm
geht deine Hände sind aber deine Hände
sind aber relativ
das ist schon
okay der ist heiß der Tee warte mal komm
ich stell den noch mal so oder so Pass
nicht D ausgipt also einfach ein sehr
ungewöhnlicher Schlafplatz und eine sehr
ungewöhnliche Lage so innerhalb von
Berlin antonia und Matze würden den Mann
gerne in eine Notübernachtung bringen
doch er lehnt ab er habe schlechte
Erfahrungen gemacht und will hier
draußen in der Kälte bleiben gute Nacht
ich glaube im Großen und
Ganzen sehn sich jeder Mensch
nach nach Nähe und auch nach Wärme den
Menschen die wir begegnen und die uns
beispielsweise ablehnt gegenüber treten
oder die sagen ich bleibbe lieber hier
das einzige was in meinen Kopf kommt ist
dass ich mir nicht vorstellen will was
irgendwann mal in deren Leben passiert
ist warum sie so eine krasse Barriere
haben wieder in irgendwie
gesellschaftliche Strukturen
zurückzukehen und lieber alleine bleiben
das sind meine Gedanken dazu ich glaub
ich würde mir wünschen dass
die Mens wenn sie durch die Stadt gehen
und irgendwie auf Obdachlose Personen
treffen oder vielleicht auch in der Bahn
oder so die Menschen überhaupt erstmal
wahnnehmen sie angucken vielleicht mal
ein Lächeln schenken und den Leuten
bisschen mehr auf Augenhöhe begegnen
wenn man die Zeit
hat mal für ein kurzes Gespräch oder
so kann das schon total viel
[Musik]
bewirken jede Nacht ist die Stadtmission
mit drei kältebussen in Berlin unterwegs
hinzu kommen zwei wärmebusse vom
Deutschen Roten Kreuz hier ist Kaffee
danke schön und doch kommen sie kaum
hinterher auch in dieser Nacht können
sie nicht alle Meldungen
abarbeiten ich kann nicht garantieren
dass wir es
schaffen früher waren bei Minusgraden
drei U-Bahnhöfe die ganze Nacht geöffnet
jetzt nicht mehr wärmende Rückzugsorte
sind rar geworden die Leute werden
überall verdrängt so ne die riechen
unangenehm die machen Dreck
die sind manchmal laut angetrunken
psychotisch überall Security am vor 10
Jahren waren noch viele sparkassenhallen
und so nutzbar überall sitzen securities
drin ist alles keine Rückzugsorte mehr
so antonia ist 25 Jahre alt sie studiert
soziale Arbeit matze ist 41
Sozialarbeiter und seit 13 Jahren mit
dem Kältebus
unterwegs ich glaube das ist einfach
sehr ehrliche und sehr authentische
Arbeit wo es wirklich darum geht dass
ich mich mit meiner Persönlichkeit
einbringe und meine Persönlichkeit der
Schlüssel ist der Türen öffnet und der
Veränderung bewirkt und das ist doch das
schönste wenn man sich in sogar auf
Arbeit in dem Rahmen bewegen kann wo man
so sein kann wie man
ist in den Notunterkünften der
Hauptstadt gibt es 1000 Schlafplätze
mindestens 400 mehr wären nötig sagt das
keltebuseam kurz nach Mitternacht sind
wieder alle Plätze belegt dann eine
Meldung eine Gruppe Obdachloser muss
raus a an dem U-Bahnhof einer von ihnen
sitzt im
Rollstuhl
Marel hallo
Marel antonia und Matze kennen die drei
die Männer haben selbst beim Kältebus
angerufen wieder ganz schön spät
angerufen klar dass der Kältebus kein
Taxi ist helfen will sie den drei
natürlich trotzdem sie telefoniert
Notunterkünfte ab die rollstuhltauglich
sind wir haben hier gerade noch drei
Männer für die suchen wir nur Unterkunft
wie sieht's bei euch aus währenddessen
erzählt Christian dass er seit 10 Jahren
obdachlos ist seit seine Eltern
gestorben sind im Rollstuhl sitze er
weil er ins Gleisbett gefallen sei und
sich dabei mehrere Knochen gebrochen
habe was mir Freude machen würde wenn
ich wier Wohnung BEK ne ein
Zimmerwohnung da würde ich mal drüber
freuen alle weiteres
nebenächlich aber es gibt keine mehr
hier in Berlin ist
schwierig Z diese Nacht haben Sie Glück
trotz später Stunde hat Antonia eine
Unterkunft
gefunden ja okay ja hier schlafen gute
Nacht ja ja ja genau
tut tut es ist mittlerweile 1:30 noch
eine halbe Stunde bis zum
Einsatzende bisschen platt bisschen
frustriert üb System
dass wir nicht so arbeiten können wie
wir es uns eigentlich
vorstellen kling wieder das
Telefon
aber es sind auch immer so ein paar
schöne Momente die man irgendwie am
Abend hatte die dann so mit in
Erinnerung bleiben und die noch so
mitschwingen und man freut sich
natürlich über die Leute die man
unterbringen konnte ich glaube dass also
so wie nach jeder Nacht man weiß man
konnte nicht jedem helfen und man konnte
nicht
irgendwie allem Genüge tun aber den dem
wir begegnet sind da haben wir auf jeden
Fall den Unterschied gemacht und das das
ist das Fazit
ja sie haben Wärme gespendet auf den
kalten Straßen der Hauptstadt mit ihrem
Bus und mit ganzem
Herzen